what up guys welcome to the just curly
things YouTube channel today I am going
to be reacting to some video that that
quotes
that comedian
I don't know some comedian that blessing
showed me
before I start don't forget to subscribe
to the channel and click that
notification Bell that we are going to
be notified of my daily videos also if
you guys want to see what blessing looks
like donate for a camera Tony
um another Super thanks and Super Chat
since this is premiering below okay
let's get started I don't know who I'm
more tired of the [__] is atmosphere or
rude are you trying to trigger me I
thought I was going out of the manager
not Kanye I love Kanye no he has been
wild but it's okay
is there one red pill dude who's like
girl didn't get [__] while he watched
in her life
I mean Rolo tomasi's been married like
25 yeah I'm just saying I I can't I
can't say a hundred percent that that
didn't happen but I'll say I don't think
it happened is there one of them who
there isn't a story where like their
girl didn't get [__] while they watch
it is is being is being in the
manuscript of the rep all right you know
how like and I'm curious about this
you're like the most homophobic guys
secretly want [__] yes okay yeah right
do they secretly want cups
it's interesting because he's using like
the shaming language that women which is
so interesting to me like when a woman
can't refute an argument he typically
goes like personal and he's a comedian
so I know he's probably trying to be
funny but like how many times we heard
that from women you're gay like oh he
must be gay what about [__] and all
this other stuff like is that you trying
to throw the scent off the cocktail yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah I'm wondering a
little bit yeah they're the most blue
pill I think that's what people do with
trauma though on a real note is like
when people are traumatized they try to
act it out like a sexual fan is my note
not real no
but like people try to use like sexual
fantasies as a way to like get control
over some bad [__] that happened to him
so like a lot of these dudes that are
into like cuck [__] like their
girlfriends cheated on them and then
they're like oh I'm gonna get control of
the situation of like watch it happen I
wonder
uh no no one personally you know I heard
about the one guy my terms it's like
this weird warped way to like gain
control like when girls enjoy being a
[__] or whatever yeah
yeah they probably went through some
sexual trauma and they're trying to
desensitize themselves okay some yes I
feel like in society a lot of times when
women have bad behavior we kind of try
to excuse them from it or give a reason
as to why some girls just like being
hoes I'm just trying to be honest here
like some girls that's just that's what
they like to do you know they got
attention from a young age they liked it
and yeah um they just you know like I
know girls that were Hoenn okay not that
young but but like since like high
school and it's like I didn't think
anything happened to them I think
they're just kind of [__] that's yeah
trauma wasn't as bad like people have
like an aggressive like assault fantasy
like a rape fantasy or something oh I
heard this we had an only fans male
model in my show and he said that's the
number one thing that's like requested
was oh like um grape fantasies it went
through that they went through some type
of trauma with that and now this is a
way for them to get control over the bad
[__] that happened that makes sense
because if this if sex means nothing
then this horrible thing to happen to me
also means nothing oh so there's a
theory about that too like great
one like women are
but we are
directed to like men that can protect us
and so you know that's why women in
general are the hair pulling like that
that sort of
and there's also there's a theory
evolutionarily that they there are those
fantasies of grape because uh typically
historically One Tribe would take over
over another tribe they would have to
they would kill the children and take
the women and like the women that were
old enough and so basically
um they would have to get along with
their captor and like fall in love with
their captors so that's that's the
Theory actually it's a good coping
mechanism especially if you're a [__] so
if you watch the movie love get [__]
her brains out of yeah in front of you
yeah you know I could totally understand
why you would be like oh yeah that's
that's that's cool wait what no I don't
think they have a [__] fantasy at all no
it's this like their girl cheating on
them yeah and then they're like damn
that hurt me really bad yeah and then
they're like oh I'm gonna gain control
of this by the next girl I'm with yeah
some dude's gonna just have sex with her
brain because Manchester pretends to be
oh yeah
can we go back to reality can we go back
to reality closet it Cooks I'm agreeing
with it no I in all seriousness I think
the the frustrating thing about the
manosphere is that like I remember
having all those feelings right and I
think that these feelings you know they
come from you're younger you go through
heartbreak your girl cheats on you or
something like that and you have this
frustration where you're not in control
of your sexual Destiny and there's a
vulnerability in that and as a man
you're not women control sex right you
can't have sex with a woman against the
will yes right
um okay so I will say there has to be a
distinction between the red pill and the
manosphere the red pill is the study of
human behavior
um the manosphere is more like men's
Centric content
um
and I'm Gonna Keep listening Patrice
even had a line about that you can't
control you're gonna have sex with a
woman against a world that's rape yeah
right so at the end of the day they are
in the driver's seat with sex a hundred
percent of the time if you want to be
remotely decent human being exactly so
the other thing that you can do is you
can develop like certain skills to
increase your chances of sleeping with
the woman that you're really interested
in but at the end of the day you gotta
hope that they want to sleep right and
uh you know I think that that's what a
lot of guys go through they're like okay
I wanna that's what I did my dad gave me
that book about the pickup artist and I
read and I was like oh that's cool like
you can learn these skills that
eventually will help you get laid and it
was really appealing to me at that young
age but I think what happens is if
you're a smart dude and a lot of these
guys happen to be intelligent guys is
when you have a resentment for women
because you're not in control of your
sexual I don't find that they resent
women at all um I mean I I'm in the
manosphere and I do like men's Centric
content and I've reacted to like tons of
red pill videos I've met a lot of these
guys in real life I I don't think they
hate women or have a disdain Destiny and
you've probably had something pretty
shitty happen to do to you from a woman
like a girl took advantage of you maybe
yeah but that's like a dumb argument
because
come on unless you're us you're still
married to your high school sweetheart
everybody's been hurt like come on
you're telling me as a grown adult no
man no woman's ever hurt you like so if
the whole argument is that they
basically hate women or they have a
disdain for women they were hurt like
everybody's been hurt but it's
interesting to see like guys on the
output outside looking to maybe cheat on
you and like [__] broke your heart
yeah you match that with intellect you
can justify your feelings yes and that's
a scary thing dude that's the most
dangerous thing on earth is people who
are smart can justify anything this
woman is awful let me think of why yeah
and no no no no that's not what happened
though women women divorced men 70 to 80
of the time 90 of their college and the
whole point of the manosphere is that
men should be aware of the risk there
like I just found this out the other day
if a girl lives with you and this could
be classified as leaving her [__] at
your apartment for a couple of months
she legally can seize your asset it's
not that every woman will but it's that
every woman
can and it would think of it out of a
business active would you go into a
business deal if it goes south it's 70
to 80 percent of the time ninety percent
of she's college educated where it's a
50 50 that it'll go through like there's
a 50 chance it'll fail and if it fails
there's a 70 to 80 chance that she can
seize and has the power to seize your
ass and take your children not that the
manosphere again it's not that the
manosphere hates women the manosphere
wants men to be aware of the risk that
they are taking when they get married
because what can happen and we'll see
that that guy that jumped off that
committed suicide at Disney as some men
go into marriage and they don't know the
risks that they are taking I all women
are awful yeah and that's how I'll
protect myself from what I experience I
can't get uh I'm not I don't have the
sexual Destiny I want to have so how can
I blame everyone else everyone except me
yeah and and this is the other thing
it's not that they're blaming everyone
else it's observation when women only
swipe right five percent of the time on
dating apps how can you say that they
don't have too high of Standards like
blessings you would only date five
percent of women the top five percent of
women and someone told you to lower your
standard was that offensive if someone
said blessing I don't know if you could
date Bella Hadid would you be offended
that's like what I'm saying Bella Hadid
it's not offensive if someone says I
can't date I don't know
um an NBA player I can't date five two
percent earner like I would just feel
yeah probably it's okay to want what you
want but can you get it and this is the
thing like a lot of times guys on the
outside will say well it's like the
men's fault the men need to be more
indeed but it's like again the number
one way people are meeting is dating it
women only swipe right five percent of
the time and you could argue okay you
can meet in other areas of life but
women find 80 of men is unattractive so
if the average woman finds 80 of men to
be ugly rooted in logic yeah it's
actually not me at all it's completely
logical and it might not be your fault
like that girl might have went through
some horrible [__] yeah you know you
know we are the sum of all the
interactions yeah and this is again it's
like whenever women have bad behavior we
always excuse it so it's like if a woman
treats you a certain way oh well she
might have gone and then go through
things all the time and we don't say
it's okay for them to treat women like
[__] and he's doing this whole podcast
her life she might have had horrible uh
experiences relationships visiting with
her family and then she cheated on you
she did something really [__] up to
you but it doesn't mean necessary that
you're bad yeah but also doesn't mean
all these women are bad yes and I think
what happens is you remember on 80
amount is unattractive it's not bad it's
not saying they're horrible people the
thing is the meadow spirit is just
warning you about what women's nature is
that's it hopefully get a little bit
older and then you fall in love with a
woman who's maybe right for you and that
resentment and bitterness that you have
for the opposite sex goes away you're
also now way more control of your sexual
Destiny because you guys are in this
consensual beautiful relationship where
you want to have sex with each other
yeah so the for men okay so again an
optimistic perspective but would you go
into a deal knowing that even if the
contract works out so we're going back
to that business contract there's a one
in four chance 20 so even even if you're
in the 50 chance that the marriage works
out there's a one in four chance that
your marriage will be sexless so
essentially
your your partner your business partner
isn't doing the number one thing aside
from maybe having children that she's
supposed to do and again we are just
warning you of what female nature is and
to be aware of me I'm looking at like
the anger and the resentment and like
the almost fear of women in the mass
Fear Community and I'm like I I get that
it's not a fear it's these are what the
numbers are and the numbers are not
pretty and it was really hard for me to
wrap my head around it at first you
listen long enough the numbers aren't
pretty and I understand why men are
walking away from Marriage I also
understand why men are walking away from
women because from a legal perspective
men are kind of effed when it comes to
the legal system and I understand where
they're coming from it will grow out of
so it's hard for me to look at it and
take it seriously though I do understand
the feeling that those guys have yeah I
just hope that they develop these
relationships and the last thing I want
is them to take this advice of I don't
want to never be in a relationship I
don't I always want to be single I
always want to again I'm starting to
learn more about mgtow recently um which
is men going their own way if you don't
because they hate women but because the
laws are not fair towards men if you go
into a business contract where there's a
50 chance it'll fail and if it fails
there's a 90 chance 80 to 90 percent
chance that she gets sole custody of
your children on top of that um I just
found out about this recently but um a
lot of States basically have
um any domestic violence or assault
charges that are brought against you
they automatically assume that the woman
is the victim because
she is
um
weaker and basically she even if she
says you know what I don't want to press
charges anymore the state can still
press charges against you and that's a
really real fear for a lot of men and
like I heard a story someone DM me the
other day about his wife literally has
no legal rights it's not that every
woman will it's that every woman can and
there's a group of men that want to walk
away until the laws change and there's a
group of men that want to walk away
until the laws change
it's not I hate women it's that every
woman can a bunch of [__] is like
you're not going to lose that resentment
you're not going to lose that anger
you're not going to lose that bitter
you're not gonna build it's gonna it's
gonna become more and more yeah and
you're also going to attract the exact
women that you hate because those are
the women that are even to tolerate the
[__] that you're talking about yeah
yeah so it's like a woman who needs your
rejection to validate herself validate
herself is so empty and you're gonna
look at women as empty because that's
yeah she's got a void no it's not not
that women are empty it's like women
cannot love men and the way men can love
us love men
um for what they can do for them or
Whitman just like
I don't know love women I don't know
it's like okay if a woman loses her job
like the man will stay with her but and
the whole point is the manosphere
doesn't want you to look for something
in a woman that she can't fault or
whatever but like yeah you know I've
also noticed like I had friends who were
great I missed that resentment brought
some fire women a [__] jokes it's so
hard to write women a [__] jokes when
you love them yeah and you think they're
great yeah I mean it's
also like a different time like imagine
like you got like a book that wasn't
even that bad yeah imagine if you went
through that same [__] when you had like
social media podcasts like telling you
Clips all the time and also like
clipping certain women that are
exemplifying the behaviors that these
guys are you see every example okay the
craziest women do go viral but the whole
point is that the mindset is everywhere
and you can't avoid it all women swipe
right
five percent of the time five percent of
the time on dating apps I think eighty
percent of women filter out any guy
that's below so that's fifteen percent
of the popular we have these numbers in
front of us again it's not that all
women are terrible it's not that they're
bad people and I say in myself included
that this mindset has taken over Society
even nice well-meaning women still have
that mindset love it like gold digger
screws off
again one of the number one reasons for
divorce is financial women are more
likely to divorce their husbands when
they get a promotion at work or when
they start out earning their husbands
this isn't fun this doesn't make us look
good but even nice women will do it not
all women not that every woman will it's
that any woman can a random thing popped
up on my Instagram and it was a girl
talking about oh he told me he was gonna
be late and I was like oh that gave me
the ick I'm about to be done and there's
this idea that women can be done with
you at any moment yeah now I have a lot
of like female friends growing up I've
also dated I know that the ick doesn't
exist it doesn't exist if women will say
a lot of things just like guys say a lot
of that it is absolute [__] if a
woman likes you there's no ick that's
true that's true I agree with this part
I agree if a woman likes you she don't
it don't matter yeah you've seen a woman
feel like when guys have deal breakers
it's like if a girl but the problem is
girls want kids and sometimes they'll
marry a guy they don't really like that
much and so what the manosphere does is
say these are the signs and sometimes
even Auntie has said it on the channel
before like girls get to a certain and a
lot of times the guy does not know guy
has no idea I can think of it tell the
story I feel about I've told this story
so many times on my podcast but there
was a girl I knew in college that
basically she dated a guy fresh beer
together for a month he cheated it was
over blah blah gets with a guy's senior
year shading him they buy a house
together all the stuff she's still with
him do this day and I was at a party
once with her hooked up with the guy
from fresh bathroom and her new
boyfriend came later
he has no idea he doesn't know he's he's
her second choice
but with the men and women can hide that
very well and it's not always as obvious
as you might think
and the manosphere just says these are
the signs she's always talking about her
toxic acts no man I don't know I don't
know if you ain't got no [__] deal
breaker
convincing me every week he loves a new
girl that's [__] brain dead
[Laughter]
a brain
you got the ick for someone no no I just
have a list of things that I'm looking
for so if you look at this video like oh
my God these girls are so unrealistic
look at these tiny little things that
give them the ick it's like none of that
[__] gives them back they just didn't
like it but for the red pill that's true
I I agree with that but when women find
80 of men is unattracted like again guys
get this around eighty percent of men
that means there's a high chance she
don't like you you find the worst
example of this party that you don't
like exactly and then you're like look
at how they all look this is how they
all are which is not the black does that
with the right two exactly they all
[__] do it yeah and um but it's just
yeah I look at it in a little bit it
makes me sad yeah it makes me sad but I
understand the feeling because I had the
exact same so what do you do what do you
do if you have that feeling you're 22
you got cheated on you [__] hate all
women you're like kind of listening to
these manuscript podcasts and you're
like these guys make a lot of makes
perfect sense and the things aren't lies
you could Flex numbers in whatever way
you want and it works out perfectly so
what do you do you hope
numbers what do you Flex number that you
fall in love with a girl and then she
makes you feel like um you know usually
makes you feel like you know that's that
person for you and that you're safe
around her and you can be vulnerable
with her and you're like oh [__] wow
women can be happy because we don't get
to I didn't have a sister growing up you
didn't have a sister growing up I know a
lot of guys who were good with girls who
had sisters growing up or raised by
their mom or whatever and they weren't
like mistreating them they just
understood women and it's like hey
you're just as vulnerable as me I can
treat you well and then move on and have
sex with as many people as I want to but
I don't have to mistreat you to do it
yeah and I really think there's a lot to
like you just don't know women they're
just as vulnerable and scared as you but
because they have they're in the
driver's seat in terms of what the
outcome is you think they're like super
drunk off of power and [__] they're
just as insecure as you just as like
scared that they're gonna get rejected
as you yeah and if you can just meet
that and be like hey we're both in this
moment and if she moves on that's not a
reflection news reflection of her or
whatever she's feeling at the moment
don't take that personally yeah I think
if we didn't take rejection so
personally a lot of this would go well
that's the thing like who take
man
men or women I'm just saying something I
don't if that was the problem then
wouldn't it be more prevalent among them
sensitive and insecure like we all have
[__] been yes rejection feels that
much worse like rejection brutal painful
so because it validates all your worst
fears about you she's not saying that
she's just saying hey I'd rather not go
out with you you're saying oh I'm ugly
I'm stupid I'm XYZ so isn't it nicer to
chalk up rejection to their personality
defaults yes and not who you are as a
person that's what I would do if I was
sensitive that's what I did so they're
painting this picture that men in the
red pill are just these men that were
rejected by women and they're young and
the biggest like supporters divorced men
men that had women take their children
sometimes they're also domestic violence
that's the red the red pill is when your
wife left you takes half takes your
children and maybe gets a DV to claim on
the way out the red pill is finding out
that
I just found out about this the other
day women can in um Divorce Court accuse
a guy of domestic violence without
actually going to court for it so she
can
and I can't remember the actual name for
it but like she can do it in divorce
court without actually going to a real
court and having no real evidence of it
and then based that on why she should
get the kids the stuff whatever and if
the judge believes it
or that's what we've all done it's oh
they're all a bunch of gold diggers you
would say that if you don't got no gold
yeah right again
yeah majority of women are gold diggers
but the whole point of the red pill is
you only got so much time you could only
be a bum for so long before a girl's
Gonna Leave the number one indicate one
of the number one indicators of divorce
is or one of the number one reasons for
divorce is financial and also when women
out earn men like if you got gold you're
like she finally appreciates my
personality yeah right like we all want
to be appreciated for what we have yeah
so I mean yeah that's the tricky thing
is like these are defense mechanisms
that we all build out yeah and it's it's
hard to realize their defense mechanisms
until you have a healthy relationship so
I guess the advice is like keep dating
and have faith if that will happen you
know it's not like every single person
is miserable in a relationship we still
have relationships yeah yeah for a
[__] reason I've yet to meet this
happy guy with four girlfriends yeah
I've yet to meet him yeah I don't know
Andrew Tate seems pretty happy I think
there is a lot of men in history I'm
just being honest okay I don't want to
be in a relationship with someone that
has four girlfriends but but I think if
women if if it wasn't for the drama that
comes with four girlfriends a lot of men
would be down there's a lot of night
I've seen some videos on Tick Tock of
like some Nigerian or like someone from
Africa with like four or five wives did
you say in Zimbabwe polygamy is more
common like multiple wives Bob were in
Nigeria like where's that comment I know
I heard it from someone it was somewhere
in Africa would you want multiple wives
[Music]
if it wasn't for the drama okay imagine
no drama between the one
you take it how many would you want
were you on seven
he said he said that he couldn't think
of anyone that's happy with four wives
I'm like I feel like those Nigerian
Kings and princes I feel like they're
married
what is one there's one girl with 196. I
had 96. 100
196 wives in Nigeria what did he know
their names how many kids did he have
over 200.
oh my God
so you'd want seven one for every day of
the week would you have like one main
one
or would they all be equal equal rights
[Music]
[Laughter]
that's that's all I need does your
girlfriend watch these videos
I have one wife I can't have two wives
do you know what I mean like that's a
absolutely absurd notion there's not
unhappy married people soon to be fair
absolutely I've never seen the guy
that's juggling women all the time is
like oh I feel so happy so fulfilled for
a long period also these short-term fire
these people that are in America yeah
but it's because the drama that comes
with anyways did complain about them
that's what you're supposed to do
calling my boys up the old fellas I had
the greatest lunch with my life you
don't do that about anything you
complained he is complaining is funny
that's when it's really dangerous if he
starts telling you how great everything
is you're like oh no oh he's beaten yeah
yeah there's nothing wrong yeah we got
to save someone just hit this one
isn't that [__] up yeah that's some
craziness if you're like oh my wife and
I just get along so we never fight I'm
like yo y'all gonna break up or you're a
Monster yeah yeah every time someone
asks my wife and I how our marriage is
doing my wife offers up this piece of
information she goes well we hear the
first year is the hardest
[Laughter]
is good go out there complain get it out
get it out the system yeah but have
faith that there are beautiful
relationships out there and beautiful
relationships don't mean that every
Roller tomasi King in the manosphere
because men and women are Better
Together We Are Better Together but the
problem is the laws today disadvantage
meant an incentivized women's bad
behavior so if a woman what's kind of in
between she might leave she might not
leave today she's every reason to leave
she's paid too every single [__] day
is peachy and clean and happy yeah
you're gonna still argue you're gonna
still I mean disagree on things that's
what life is yeah that was huge for me I
didn't know because I grew up with all
fights being huge yeah and then when I
actually learned like yo fighting's
supposed to happen it doesn't have to
get crazy I was like oh oh this is
normal we're okay yeah I think you also
so much is fear but what I was gonna say
to you one piece of advice I think we're
all kind of realizing that alpha male
beta male [__] is kind of like I feel
like his testosterone is low and I don't
know why it's something with vocal
tonality when guys have like kind of
like a I will say this okay and this is
no disrespect no some guys could be hot
but if they have a certain voice you
should have a deeper voice I'm just that
like I don't know what it it just kind
of it just makes you kind of like more
girly I don't know I don't know sorry
I'm not really real yeah but I would say
this if you had a picture of what an
alpha male was would it be somebody
who's so insecure that he needs to
mistreat a woman to keep her with him or
to be somebody who's like hey I'mma
treat you well and if you move on that's
fun all the dudes in front of me that's
cool yeah
I don't know anyone I mean you know what
you know what's crazy too most of these
manosphere men will say to pay all the
bills
like I swear to God I swear to God most
of them say that you should pay
you should yeah
sometimes okay I'm sorry guys and I I
honestly like I like this I've seen this
podcast before I don't know their names
I like but it just kind of sometimes
like guys get offended by things that
I'm not even offended about I'm just
like okay ah I don't want to call them
[__] but it's what I'm thinking it's
what I'm thinking and I'm just trying to
be honest I'm sorry edit this out if I
shouldn't say it no please don't leave
it in leave it in okay that is the most
outfit the coolest guy just take a smash
who needs a towel yeah I mean that guy's
really cool yeah that's the most Alpha
dude yeah yeah shout out shout out the
man is fear though
oh yeah yeah yeah how much longer do you
think that exists forever I think yeah
just different iterations of it probably
yeah yeah you know how that we had
Atkins and now it's just called keto
there's gonna be another man of spear in
10 years yeah after this goes away it
can be the same [__] different name yeah
yeah I mean as long as it produces funny
[__] like you could argue that
so much of my [__] man is fear but be
funny about it at least like that to be
honest that's what was working for Tate
yes the dude was [__] hilarious funny
and unique takes unique takes oh that's
so redeeming yeah I
heard it put like this before yeah
it's a great airplane joke you're like
God like I don't let a woman dry my
Bugatti because have you ever thrown a
ball to a woman seen her catch it
true and I go okay I literally threw her
like a peach in my hand it immediately
actually no she caught it and then her
phone fell out of her pocket cracked on
the ground True Story I played
basketball and volleyball I would catch
it
maybe okay
I was like there's no way there's no way
dude
my wife doesn't let me drive what does
that mean am I am I an alpha
yo it's that simple just be funny about
it yeah the angry manosphere dude or the
one who takes it seriously I want to
know who's angry
yeah clown clown nobody want to hear
that yeah that's terrible like even when
you're hanging with your boys and you're
making jokes about women it's funny yeah
there's no dude in the group who's like
yo [__] these [__] that's weird man
that's weird too intense what's wrong
with you yeah
that's crazy are you angry a woman
unless you dump a load on her belly what
they let you do that sometimes yeah how
you angry at that yeah that's what they
prefer because you can't do it that's
why he's angry oh you're saying they
don't get any [__] yeah oh because all
these Chads and gigging chats right here
just banging all the chicks oh what is a
giga Chad I thought that was a toy of
some kind of keychain that's that Ultra
Chad bro that's like you seen the guy
was like are these guys chats okay this
is just Vibes alone I'll tell you you
know it's hard I hate my commentary
sometimes change that even changes
sometimes I want to be less brutally
honest at times because I'm like I might
meet these people in real life where
when I was small I was like you could
just wild anyways
um but I'm gonna do it anyway sometimes
I think should I do this guy in a left
chat on a podcast he's probably got
money uh good looking I would say he's
cute chat guy in the middle not a chat
he's got his legs crossed um he's got
Fame so maybe that elevates him into
chat but I'd say naturally not a chat
Chad not a Chad
um guy on the right I feel like growing
up he was a borderline Chad because he
was always funny cute and Tall however I
feel like when he got famous then he
became Chad territory so Chad not a Chad
Chad your jawline yeah that guy's Giga
chat so they're getting all the girls
yeah is what they're saying I'm like
looking at him I'm like he's probably
talking about himself he's cute and
that's how the world works
name a species where this doesn't
operate like that that's true hold on
these manosphere dudes all of a sudden
Communists with the coochie they want to
equally spread around I think that's why
you want to have millions of dollars to
have family okay okay I don't even think
most men in the manosphere would say it
should be equally spread around okay
they're just saying if you're gonna go
for a top five percent man you're gonna
get cheated on you're gonna get cheated
up like it's just it just is what it is
I don't make the rules we don't make the
rules here I just tell you what they are
the cars but when it comes to [__] you
want that [__] to be what is it Adam
Smith
Karl Marx yeah you know what I mean no
no no I think they're saying that's why
you need to be a high value man so you
can get these girls that's like part of
it yeah but they don't want to do that
yeah yeah they love that the [__] was
just there yeah right but so the fact
that you have to go achieve this thing
what are they understanding that these
are the rules yeah um yeah so not
everything they say is some toxic [__]
like yeah sure go be that go make them
the money you want but then actually
feel that on the inside don't just make
money and then be like oh you can get
laid I mean I know people are going to
say like you're six two and beautiful
but like that I know they're gonna say
like you're six to absolutely beautiful
and have a full beard but like
you're five seven and gorgeous and
you've never had sex with anyone except
one person exactly so you know that yeah
but I need knowing though yeah
I value bro high value yo you know if
you ever want to feel good about
yourself tell a dude that don't get no
[__] that it's easy to get [__]
because people explain everything about
two that makes you get [__] oh yeah
long legs
hey look here look at they just speak
facts though they just speak facts
they're at an advantage in the world
[__] amazing even the guy in the
middle he's cute too
I'm sorry I'm sorry I think he wants to
[__] you I think he might want to yeah
that's the thing I don't get why they're
so mad at women it seems like they're
mad at other dudes that are banging all
the women like you're they're not mad at
women right what the dating Market is
like
they describe women's nature it's not
that every woman can't will it's not
that every woman Wills that every woman
can out of other dudes that are higher
than you in the hierarchy yeah so like
direct your anger towards them also
don't make money before you get posted
you don't have to make money I agree
with that you get [__] at all make sure
you get [__] before you make money
because I don't think you'll ever be
able to respect women if you ain't
getting no [__] then you made money and
then you start getting [__] because now
it confirms your worst nightmares and
you're probably hanging around women
that genuinely like you for your money
exactly that small percentage of women
that only do that yeah you're gonna get
confirmation uh no girls stand with a
bum that long no girl staying with the
bump if dude is literally not working
dude's leaving your ass that's what I'm
saying women and men love differently
where if a woman's not working
hey I'm leaving you and then when you
find a girl who doesn't really care but
actually likes you you're not gonna
trust it at all
and that yeah that's you number one do
not make it do not become a high value
man before you get some [__] the worst
advice I could ever give men for truly
loving and appreciating women is
becoming a high value man and against a
[__] get some [__] when you're the
lowest value man yeah because then you
look that was an interesting video
maybe it's funny I thought he made some
points but I don't think he really
wasn't compassing what I would say the
manosphere is and what a lot of us would
say I don't find that the men in the
manosphere are um sexist at all I just
think they describe women's nature based
on observations experience and data
that's what I would say uh but let me
know if you disagree in the comments
don't forget to subscribe to the channel
and bring that notification Bell I will
talk to you next time
foreign